[Musique]
c'est moi oui c'est moi oui en effet ouais
ça a l'air vraiment faux n'est-ce pas
c'est génial n'est-ce pas je sais que c'est
vraiment amusant ouais c'est parti
partout donc ouais j'en suis très fier  est
une expérience assez incroyable, je veux dire
que vous vous rapprochez probablement le plus
possible de ce rêve que nous avons parfois
vous savez
voler vous savez quand vous rêvez et
vous imaginez que vous pouvez simplement aller
où vous voulez aller  je me sens un
peu comme ça
j'ai été un négociant en pétrole avec bp pendant 16 ans
mais toute ma famille venait du monde
de l'aviation et de l'ingénierie
et j'aime un défi j'aime prendre
quelque chose que je pense impossible ou
peut-être que tout le monde pense qu'il est impossible de s'y
habituer  le fait que
tout le monde a raison généralement comme disons
19 fois sur 20 mais une fois sur
quand il s'avère que c'est possible, je trouve
cela trop excitant pour ignorer que
vous savez comme une sorte de britannique misérable
et je vais dire  pareil
pour le français aussi
contrairement au a  les américains nous ne nous appellerions jamais
comme des super-héros, les
américains sont très heureux d'
établir ce lien avec vous savez les
super-héros de merveille et des choses
je pense que nous devrions faire plus de cela en
europe, je pense que nous devrions je pense que
nous devrions embrasser le pouvoir de
euh vous  connaissez le genre d'idées de bande dessinée
parce qu'elles représentent souvent la vraie
créativité humaine si souvent ouais la science-
fiction pointe vers les ambitions vraiment cool
que nous avons en tant qu'humains
alors oui ce n'est pas comme ça que j'ai commencé mais c'est
très cool que les gens pensent que ça
ressemble  Iron Man
[Musique]
Je veux dire, évidemment, les humains sont capables
de voler depuis environ 100 ans, mais
euh en termes de vol dans un genre vraiment cool
de très intime pour vous en quelque sorte
ouais euh j'aimerais penser que nous avons le
le plus proche jusqu'à présent,
nous pouvons généralement former la plupart des gens en
une journée une demi-journée
avec la sécurité ouais avec l'
attache de sécurité pour apprendre à faire cela,
cela semble fou mais c'est un peu comme
apprendre à faire du vélo,
vous ne pouvez pas vraiment lire un  livre, vous devez
simplement aller le
sentir et vous vous rendez compte qu'il est super
équilibré et stable, vous savez si vous
commencez à tomber de cette façon
ou que faites-vous naturellement, vous tendez le
bras, n'est-ce pas bien si vous tendez le
bras et  vous avez une poussée qui en
sort,
votre cerveau va oh c'est comme vraiment
très intuitif et il ne faut pas
très longtemps pour apprendre,
alors j'ai lancé cette entreprise comme je le dis
il y a quatre ans avec le rêve de
réimaginer le vol humain dans un vraiment
manière agile qui utiliserait votre cerveau d'un
point de vue équilibré et votre corps est
la structure de vol et je pensais juste que
ce serait un défi cool car le
film militaire montre que cela a un
rôle croissant à jouer
dans certains domaines de mobilité de niche
euh nous  Je ne suggère pas que les gens vont
les utiliser comme voler dans la rue
et aller dans les magasins que vous connaissez déjà, mais
nous sommes sur le point de lancer notre version électrique
en juillet et si les batteries deviennent de
plus en plus légères,
ne dites jamais jamais ca  rs ont
commencé à être vraiment pauvres et
nuls par rapport à un cheval
et regardez où les voitures se sont retrouvées, alors ne
dites jamais jamais nous avons fait un film de recherche et de
sauvetage avec un groupe d'ambulances aériennes,
nous avons volé jusqu'à la montagne et sommes arrivés à la
victime en 90 secondes
quand il a fallu  20 minutes pour y aller à pied afin que
vous puissiez obtenir le premier intervenant médical
très rapidement
comme un ambulancier sur une moto à travers
la circulation,
nous avons donc établi le record du monde Guinness à 85
milles à l'heure 135 kilomètres à l'heure, je
veux dire que nous pouvons aller plus vite ça devient juste  assez
dangereux,
nous pouvons aller aussi haut que vous le souhaitez vraiment, je
veux dire que vous pouvez aller à des milliers de pieds, mais
nous allons rarement très haut du tout parce
que cela redevient dangereux et
vulnérable et vous êtes loin d'un
public si vous faites un  événement,
puis combien de temps cela va-t-il voler
environ cinq six minutes environ, ce qui
ne semble pas très long, mais parce que
vous êtes si agile
et que vous pouvez atterrir et éteindre et faire
quelque chose et recommencer dans les
15 secondes et  voler à nouveau vous ne  pas besoin
d'autant de temps de vol, ce n'est pas
censé être en concurrence avec un hélicoptère volant
pendant deux heures, ce n'est pas vraiment l'idée que
vous